este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
bling ist seguro que al igual que a mí
muchas veces tienes la sensación de que
no te da el tiempo para ponerte a leer
tantos libros como te gustaría o como
solía hacer que si exámenes el trabajo
al final siempre hay algo que se acaba
interponiendo o me equivoco bueno pues
que me dirías si te dijera que existe
una app que te resume en 15 minutos
miles de libros de no ficción en inglés
de todo tipo y no solo el texto sino
también en formato de audio pues el caso
es que esa app existe y tiene un nombre
blink ist una de las cosas que más nos
soléis pedir es que os recomendamos
libros bueno pues en blink s
encontraréis muchos de los que siempre
os decimos apuestas seguras para todos
los que seguís visual polític son por
ejemplo fax bulnes o porque fracasan los
países también encontraréis obras de
pinter o taleb que seguro encontráis muy
interesantes o si os gusta yo que sé el
mundo de la inversión pues tenéis nada
menos que el inversor inteligente
[Música]
los primeros 100 de vosotros que vayáis
a blind kiss puntocom
visual polític s tendréis acceso
ilimitado por una semana para aprobarlo
totalmente gratis y si no os convence
podéis cancelarlo sin problema durante
esos siete días y en caso de que os
guste disfrutaréis también además de un
25% de descuento para un full membership
y sin más comencemos con el vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
chile era el país más estable y más
próspero de américa latina'
[Aplausos]
todo un modelo a seguir una especie de
experimento para demostrar que incluso
en latinoamérica escapar de la pobreza
no era una meta imposible
sin embargo el pasado octubre de 2019
todo este sueño comenzó a romperse en
mil pedazos
de repente enormes olas de violencia y
gigantescas movilizaciones políticas
estallaron por todo el país en apenas
unas semanas el país estaba en llamas
desde que arrancaron las protestas más
de 25 personas se han perdido la vida
los heridos se cuentan por miles más de
25.000 locales han sido afectados por
incendios saqueos o destrozos el metro
de santiago ha sufrido daños por valor
de cientos de millones de dólares y la
economía se ha parado para que os hagáis
una idea según los datos del gobierno
los daños económicos se sitúan entre los
2.000 y los 3.000 millones de dólares
queridos amigos de visual política en
este vídeo os contamos qué diantres ha
pasado en chile por qué ha ocurrido y
que viene por delante atentos
[Música]
la llama que prendió la mecha la
explosión social de octubre fue una
sorpresa que pilló a todo el mundo
desprevenido
fijaos el punto de inflexión se produjo
cuando el gobierno chileno decidió
incrementar el precio de los billetes de
metro de santiago en 30 pesos unos 4
centavos de dólar sí lo sé no era
precisamente un gran incremento pero
amigos digamos que esa fue la excusa el
motivo la llama que prendió la mecha
[Música]
de repente cientos de estudiantes
comenzaron a protestar entrando en el
metro sin pagar pero la cosa no se quedó
ahí poco a poco se desmadró del todo
[Música]
fijaos estamos hablando del lunes 14 de
octubre pues bien para el sábado 19 el
metro ya estaba en llamas sí si lo
habéis escuchado bien en llamas la mitad
de las estaciones del metro de la
capital de santiago habían sufrido
ataques vandálicos y más de 20 estaban
ardiendo literalmente estaban siendo
reducidas a cenizas
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea tan solo los
daños provocados en la jornada del
sábado 19 se estiman en 200 millones de
dólares piñera anuncia el estado de
excepción en chile tras fuerte explosión
de violencia por la subida de las
tarifas de metro pero este no era más
que el comienzo en los días sucesivos la
cosa se puso aún peor y las protestas se
extendieron al resto del país
de repente supermercados tiendas
autobuses incluso edificios enteros
fueron víctimas del vandalismo y los
saqueos chile ya no se parecía a chile
al chile que todos teníamos en mente
grupos tremendamente radicalizados
querían terminar con el llamado modelo
chileno a golpe de revolución
[Aplausos]
por supuesto tal y como os podéis
imaginar en un primer momento la policía
no se andó con chiquitas y respondió con
fuerza con mano dura y si puede que
hayas escuchado todo lo contrario pero
lo cierto es que sobre esta cuestión las
principales organizaciones de derechos
humanos coinciden desde el alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos hasta
organizaciones como human rights watch
han recopilado pruebas y acreditado como
en muchos casos los cuerpos de seguridad
chilenos los carabineros se excedieron y
se extralimitaron en el uso de la fuerza
datos por ejemplo del propio ministerio
de salud los servicios de urgencias
atendieron a más de 11 mil 500 personas
como consecuencia de las manifestaciones
de todas ellas 1100 que se dice pronto
presentaban lesiones moderadas o graves
y la cosa no acaba aquí hay más de 350
denuncias sobre malos tratos torturas y
abusos hacia los detenidos factores como
el uso indiscriminado indebido de armas
y escopetas antidisturbios abusos contra
personas detenidas y sistemas de control
interno deficientes facilitaron que se
produjeran graves violaciones de los
derechos de muchos chilenos josé miguel
vivanco protestas en chile informe de la
onu reitera que se han producido un
elevado número de violaciones graves a
los derechos humanos en cualquier caso
para no equivocarnos aquí hay dos
detalles muy importantes que tenemos que
tener muy en cuenta
[Música]
primero con esto no queremos justificar
en absoluto la acción de los violentos
para nada todo lo contrario estos grupos
radicales violentos agresivos que
merecen toda nuestra condena no tuvieron
ningún reparo en atacar a los propios
carabineros con piedras bancos y con
todo lo que pillaran incluso con
'cócteles molotov' por no hablar de los
saqueos los robos las intimidaciones
cetera etcétera
ellos también han sido víctimas de estos
hechos de violencia de hecho al día de
hoy tenemos más de 2500 carabineros
heridos o lesionados algunos de ellos de
gravedad- sebastián piñera pero por otro
lado hay que decir que la mayoría de los
manifestantes se comportaron de forma
pacífica y muchos sufrieron las
consecuencias de una policía que
simplemente no estaba preparada para lo
que se les estaba viniendo encima chile
llamado urgente a una reforma policial
tras las protestas uso excesivo de la
fuerza contra manifestantes y
transeúntes graves abusos en detención y
es que no penséis que las protestas en
chile han sido cosas sólo de unos pocos
radicales
para nada
el 25 de octubre es un día que pasará a
la historia de chile 11 días después de
estallar las revueltas 12 millones de
personas de acuerdo a las estadísticas
oficiales se echaron a la calle para
manifestarse contra la situación del
país contra el rumbo del país
ojo que hablamos de más del 20 por
ciento de la población de santiago
así que llegados a este punto lo que
tenemos que preguntarnos es realmente
están justificadas protestas de este
tipo en el país más próspero de américa
latina- pues amigos yo os adelanto que
aquí tenemos una de cal y otra de arena
chile es un país que tiene un patrimonio
sanitario que nos ha costado mucho
conquistar y que tenemos que cuidar con
mucho rigor que nos permite ser un
proveedor de alimentos seguros y sanos
para el resto del mundo tenemos tratados
de libre comercio con las principales
economías del mundo
30 años cómo ha cambiado chile en 30
años
empecemos por la mejor cara
no son 30 pesos son 30 años este ha sido
el lema principal de unas protestas que
poco a poco han ido justificándose por
la elevada desigualdad que padecen los
chilenos como consecuencia de ese
sistema que ha imperado en las últimas
tres décadas
pero amigos realmente ha sido tan malo
este periodo de tiempo pues lo cierto es
que no
[Música]
fijaos en cómo ha evolucionado por
ejemplo la pobreza
[Música]
si le ha pasado de ser uno de los países
más pobres de latinoamérica a luchar por
la primera plaza de los más ricos y más
desarrollados de hecho si nos fijamos en
el índice de desarrollo humano y además
de variables económicas incluye otras
como la atención sanitaria la educación
o por ejemplo la esperanza de vida chile
se sitúa en el primer puesto regional
[Música]
respecto a si hablamos de desigualdad es
verdad que chile tiene mucha desigualdad
pero no es cierto ni mucho menos que sea
el país más desigual de latinoamerica
para nada
[Música]
en cambio sí que es uno de los países de
la región donde más se ha reducido la
desigualdad en los últimos años esto no
es mi opinión y la de visual polític son
los datos y es que de hecho si en vez de
fijarnos en la desigualdad total nos
fijamos en los niveles de desigualdad
entre las personas que están en el mismo
rango de edad vemos como la desigualdad
es mucho menor entre las generaciones
más jóvenes es algo similar a lo que
ocurre con la educación
[Música]
si echamos un vistazo encontraremos que
chile tiene un porcentaje de población
con educación secundaria inferior a la
media de la ocde pero si en cambio nos
fijamos en que ocurre con los chilenos
que tienen entre 25 y 34 años entonces
estos ya superan el promedio de los
países más ricos
y no es algo extraño es una
característica muy habitual de los
países que han crecido muy rápido es
fácil encontrar características muy
diferentes entre la población según la
generación a la que pertenezca una parte
habrá crecido y vivido en un país pobre
y la otra en un país desarrollado
pero tal vez la mejor forma de
aproximarnos a todo este jaleo sea de la
mano de rodrigo valdés ministro de
hacienda en el segundo mandato de
michelle bachelet vagos que no hablamos
de ningún libertario radical
precisamente pues fijaos en el año 2018
este buen señor presentó un paper
académico en la harvard kennedy school
donde venía a decir dos cosas
primero que la izquierda se estaba
equivocando de cabo a rabo en empeñarse
tanto con el tema de la desigualdad
porque para combatirla el crecimiento
económico era mucho más importante que
la redistribución y segundo que en los
últimos 30 años los que más han visto
incrementada su renta han sido
precisamente los más pobres mirad vamos
en otras palabras que lo que el país
necesita sobre todo es más crecimiento
económico y por ahí vienen en cierto
modo los problemas porque ya os he dicho
que teníamos una de cal y otra de arena
tienen los chilenos motivos para
quejarse atentos
motivos para el desencanto
amigos que muchas cosas hayan marchado
bien no quiere decir que los chilenos no
tengan motivos para sentirse defraudados
defraudados esa es la palabra a los
chilenos se les prometió unos resultados
que no terminan de llegar a pesar de
todo lo que hemos visto hay cosas que
bueno no son tan positivas
[Música]
el país tiene un nivel de productividad
muy bajo que sigue lastrando los
salarios más de tres quintas partes de
toda la población es clase media que
vive en el límite por lo que es
vulnerable a perder por cualquier
circunstancia sobrevenida ese escalón y
la economía en otra hora el gran orgullo
de los chilenos ya prácticamente no
crece no al menos en los términos per
cápita los últimos años están siendo
bastante pobres
y claro si la economía no crece y los
salarios reales tampoco crecen pues la
cosa no va por buen camino no os parece
y no sólo eso las pensiones otra de las
grandes promesas que se le hicieron a
los chilenos son muy bajas para que os
hagáis una idea la mitad de las
pensiones que se pagaron en los últimos
meses apenas rondaron 123 mil pesos unos
160 dólares al mes
[Música]
vamos una auténtica miseria y ojo que os
conozco a muchos de vosotros no es que
el sistema el sistema de pensiones de
capitalización de chile sea malo para
nada lo que ocurre es que los ciudadanos
por un lado no lo conocen porque no se
les ha explicado debidamente cómo
funciona y por otro lado el gobierno ha
hecho una dejación de funciones casi
total
[Música]
por un lado no ha controlado que los
tiempos de cotización fueran adecuados y
por otro no se preocupó de establecer
una mínima red de seguridad para
aquellas personas que no lograron
cotizar lo suficiente la combinación es
explosiva porque supone que la gente
entiende que un buen sistema es un mal
sistema porque las pensiones que reporta
son muy pero que muy bajas
y es que fijaos tal y como está montado
el sistema es una bomba de relojería los
hombres se jubilan a los 65 años con
apenas 18 años cotizados de media y en
el caso de las mujeres es aún peor se
jubilan con 60 años y 13 cotizados de
media
[Música]
que han hecho el resto del tiempo
economía informal acuerdos bajo la mesa
para no cotizar etcétera etcétera y
vamos a ver cómo se pueden soportar 20 o
30 años de jubilación si sólo se han
contribuido 13 15 o 18 aportando sólo el
10 por ciento del salario es que no se
puede son números es imposible que las
pensiones sean más altas pero por este
motivo
i
y con un sistema de reparto la cosa a
medio plazo ojo podría ser aún mucho
peor si no se cotiza el sistema
simplemente no funciona ni de una forma
ni de otra
[Música]
y si a todo esto le sumamos la sensación
de que las divisiones sociales siguen
muy presentes en la sociedad ahora ya
podemos entender la enorme frustración
que alimenta las protestas aunque a ver
esto es mi opinión pero la verdad es que
si lo pensáis un momento parece un poco
injusto que se focalicen contra un
presidente que ganó las elecciones hace
tan poco tiempo más aún cuando de los
casi 30 años de democracia en chile la
izquierda que ahora forma parte de las
protestas ha gobernado prácticamente 25
hombres algo habrán tenido que ver con
el modelo no os parece
[Música]
en casa amigos es que las expectativas
no se están cumpliendo eso es un hecho
que en cierto modo es algo que se
explica con la conocida como ley de
wagner una tesis que defiende que a
mayor riqueza mayores son las presiones
para que el estado suministre más y más
bienes sociales y claro cuanto más
pequeño sea el estado más fuerza tendrá
esta dinámica pero ahora la pregunta es
y ahora qué
[Música]
la salida del túnel
en fin creo que ahora podemos entender
mucho mejor que ha ocurrido en chile
durante los últimos tiempos pero la
pregunta es que vendrá a salir a este
problema de momento lo que está haciendo
piñera son dos cosas
[Música]
por un lado poner en marcha una agenda
social que entre otras muchas cuestiones
incrementará las pensiones más bajas y
establecerá un ingreso mínimo vital es
decir las personas que trabajen y no
alcancen los 350 mil pesos verán cómo el
gobierno complementa sus nóminas
[Música]
por otro lado se ha acordado que en 2020
se le preguntará a los chilenos acerca
de si quieren cambiar su constitución a
pesar de que la constitución chilena ha
sufrido 219 cambios desde que se
produjera la transición democrática el
último importante en el 2005
este es un día muy grande para chile
tenemos razones para celebrar tenemos
hoy por fin una constitución democrática
acorde con el espíritu de chile ricardo
lagos presidente de chile entre el 2000
y el 2006 pues se equivocaba porque al
parecer ya no vale decir que queréis que
os diga más allá de que no es
recomendable andar cambiando de
constitución todos los días ni generar
falsas expectativas lo que sí le
necesita es concentrarse en volver a
crecer sólo así podrá superar de verdad
todos los problemas a los que se
enfrenta en fin espero que con este
vídeo puedes entender mejor todo lo que
ha acontecido durante los últimos
tiempos por el país sudamericano desde
aquí desde visual político estaremos muy
atentos a cómo discurren los
acontecimientos ahora abramos debate
esperamos vuestros mensajes en los
comentarios de nuevo gracias a bling is
a visual política y a su comunidad como
no muchas gracias a vosotros por estar
ahí como siempre un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]